it's Matthew 2 veres 1- 2 Matthew 2:8
and Matthew 21 the Magi the magy magy
the Magi the wise men from the East they
come and they tell Herod where he where
is he born King of the Jews for we have
seen a star and we've come to worship
Him worship Him
Pro now some translations will say to
honor him or reverence him or bow down
to him I don't know your translation how
it reads
how does it read all right so Matthew
2:2 Matthew 2 verse one-2 to see who
they are okay it is worship though but
it says now after Jesus was born in
Bethlehem of Judea in the days of Herod
the king behold wise men from the East
came to Jerusalem saying where is he who
has been born King of the Jews for we
have seen his star in the east and have
come to worship Him okay now
I want everyone to see the wise men in
the Greek word is magy mag Magi Magi if
you read the Greek versions of Daniel so
I'm gonna have to sum this up because
I've done I've done sessions on this in
the Greek versions of
Daniel the word astrologers is
translated
magy there so the Magi from the East are
the spiritual descendants of the Magi at
the time of Daniel go look up the word
astrologers in Daniel in the Greek it's
mag it's the same word everyone with me
because you're going to see the
connection here yeah I know you're with
me I'm down to the rest of them everyone
with me I'm the only one that can
respond really right now no but I'm
looking at the YouTube channel as well
oh okay all right so the word magy is
the same word used in the Greek
translation of Daniel for the
astrologers and so you're going to see
why these wise men knew so much about
Jesus because they were the spiritual
descendants of the Magi who had seen
Daniel filled with the Holy Spirit
prophesy that the king of Israel would
come who's the son of man who rides the
Clouds Of Heaven who is God in flesh
distinct from the Ancient of Days whom
All Nations must worship Daniel 7 9-10
and 13 and
14 okay so in Daniel's prophecy he sees
the son of man coming in the Clouds Of
Heaven approaching ancient days he's
given a kingdom that's Immortal
indestructible All Nation
in all languages must worship him
forever Daniel is
prophesying not only for us but for them
for the calans the Chans the astrologers
and susers so they would have known
these promises because Daniel would have
shared it with them as he shared it with
the King to influence them to worship
the god of Israel keep that in mind so
they knew from the prophecy that Daniel
saw a king of Israel son of man coming
one who is human but more than human in
the Clouds of of Heaven coming to the
Ancient of Days Daniel 713- 14 whose
kingdom is indestructible whom All
Nations and all languages must worship
notice All Nations all languages wise
men from the East coming to worship the
king of Israel why because they would
have known from this tradition that
would have been preserved and who knows
they may have even had a copy of Daniel
that this man this Mighty Man filled
with the spirit of the god of Israel
announced the day where their king would
come who' be God In the Flesh and all
must worship Him so when he came they
knew this is
him this is him everyone with me there
everyone got it right yeah all right now
that means they knew a lot more about
Jesus than many of us know today because
they knew this king is worthy of worship
so they're coming to worship him this is
further brought out in Matthew 21
because when they find the child with
his mother in the house what do they
do and when they had come into the house
they saw the young child with Mary his
mother and fell down and worshiped him
and when they had opened their Treasures
they presented gifts to him gold
frankincense and myrrh yeah so notice
they gave three gifts gold that's
tribute to a King frankincense incense
the word is lebanos here I'm going to
show you the lexic so you don't think
I'm lying
leanos here it is leanos
I put it in YouTube frankincense incense
this is the Greek word used for the
translation of Isaiah
60:6 and Leviticus 2 veres 1 following
where it says the priest would offer
frankincense incense to God can you read
Isaiah
60:6 you got it brother
so they gave him incense which
is what the priest offered to God in
Priestly worship because this word
libanos is the Greek translation of the
word incense in Leviticus chapter 24 but
it's also in Isaiah 60:6 now watch what
Isaiah 60:6 says and be
astonished the multitude of camels shall
cover your land the drum daries of
Midian and epha all those from Sheba
shall come and they shall bring gold and
incense and they shall proclaim the
Praises of Yahweh wait so the Kings from
Sheba will come to give who
what to bring the gold and incense and
proclaim the Praises of Yahweh so who
are they going to praise they're going
to praise and worship Yahweh and who are
they going to give incense
to to Yahweh and that word in the Greek
is lebanos incense same word
and they're going to give him gold right
right so is it a coincidence the ma give
to the child insense leanos and gold the
two things that Isaiah prophesied these
people from the nations would give to
Yahweh in honor of Yahweh and worship of
Yahweh amen so gold tribute to a King
incense because he's God incense
frankincense that's what you offer to
God not to a man but then it says also
right M the word myr is from Smyrna myr
is what Joseph of ARA and Nicodemus used
to prepare Jesus's body for burial let
me get it for you you hear me there yeah
smna
smrna okay that's the word used for the
very persecuted ointment
or what Joseph arth
and Nicodemus used to prepare Jesus for
burial here's the link and it's in John
1938-39 John 19 3839 specifically 39 it
says Joseph arthea and Nicodemus when
they took Jesus body what did they do
they they put on his body myrr they used
myrr on his body as they wrapped him and
buried him in the Tomb John 18
3839 you guys wom are you guys asleep
we're with you brother okay what does it
say and now the verse is 39 there's the
word
smrna okay so it says uh John 1838-39
right yep pilate said to him what is
truth and when he had said this he went
again to the Jews and said to them I
find no fault in him at all are you yeah
1938-39 I was in 38 John 1938 to39 okay
John
19 okay it says after this Joseph of
arthea being a disciple of Jesus but
secretly for the fear of the Jews asked
pilate that he might take away the body
of Jesus and pilate gave him permission
so he came and took the body of Jesus
and Nicodemus who had first came to
Jesus by night also came bringing a
mixture of myrr and allows wait what did
they bring myr
myrr and that was used for his
burial right and then incense lebanos is
what the priests in Leviticus Tuan give
to God and what Isaiah 60:6 says the
nations would give to God in worshiping
Yahweh amen and gold so now guys I don't
know if you're understanding this the
wise men are the Magi the spiritual
descendants of the astrologers at the
time of Daniel they knew enough about
the child that he's God In the Flesh he
would die how do we know they gave him
gold tribute to a King but also for God
who's the king incense which is what you
give to God not a creature and myrr
signifying his death how did they know
this child is God In the Flesh worthy of
their worship who would die how did they
know so much about Jesus because if you
make the connection that they are the
spiritual descendants of the Magi at
Daniel's time because the word
astrologers in the Aramaic is rendered
magy in the Greek those Magi would have
received Revelation from Daniel and may
have even had a copy of Daniel where
Daniel sees in Daniel 713- 14 and in
Daniel
92526 that the son of man one like a son
of man mean he's more than human rides
the cloud something only God does reigns
with the Ancient of Days his kingdom is
indestructible all nations from all
languages will worship him all nations
must worship him forever because he
rules over them forever but he's also
the ruler the Messiah who will be cut
off and killed violently in Daniel
92526 that means these Magi believe the
promises of Daniel because they saw the
supernatural work God did in and through
him to convince them the god of Israel
is true so they were eagerly awaiting
the king of Israel whom they knew is God
In the Flesh who would die to bring
about Everlasting righteousness but then
Reign forever and worthy of their
worship so they were worshiping him as
God in flesh the one who comes to die to
atone for their sins